hi Thomas uh I love the first few
episodes that we got to see it was very
excellent um I studied Dickens at
College uh and you know Dickens is very
much a a writer that has influence a lot
of the media that we consume today
specifically with historical dramas and
I'm curious what was like your first
introduction to Dickens uh it probably
was Oliver the movie um many years ago
with uh Oliver Reed
as as the baddy um who yeah that was I
think was the first movie that actually
scared me that and The Witches by Ral
Dar um with the two films that that that
scared me quite a lot but I loved the
um I mean I grew up in London it was a
different aesthetic it's it's um it's
it's changed a lot since then but
there's a lot of those old Victorian
buildings and I I grew up in Georgian
flat and lived
in Victorian house for a long time and
um now at another georan house so the
aesthetic is is somewhat familiar to me
but thankfully things have things have
moved on a bit since
then that was was my first introduction
to Dickens what Drew you to The Artful
Dodger uh well I always like the
character The Artful Dodger me he's my
favorite in in in Oliver um he's the fun
and in some ways perhaps the most relat
to um and I I thought the scripts were
really fun um I could I could see myself
doing it I I liked bringing Dickens to
Australia um I was kind of I I could I
could picture what that would look like
I like I like the idea of that
aesthetic um uh I also like the idea of
a of a Dodger grown up and um uh you
know trying his hand at a at a different
style of life um and
uh attempting to break away from his his
um what we all know him as being a
street
urant and and I love um David thus big
fan of him um and he was already
attached at the time and I thought I
thought um it could
be I remember thinking at the time the
world could probably do with a with a
laugh and um and some good fun and I and
I thought that this show could could do
that I love how unexpected it was I
definitely wasn't expecting for him to
be this like accomplished surgeon and
that was such a neat angle um with the
story I'm curious and like your
preparation for the role did you do any
Research into like the surgical um
practices of the time to kind of
familiarize yourself with all of that uh
I mean very Loosely but we we did we uh
the scripts were written in a
manner where they they had quite a lot
of that knowledge already built into
them a certain amount and then we we had
sessions with a surgeon to uh to really
actually break down each scene and try
and figure out exactly what surgery
would be taken place um in each scene
and then uh we would then speak with the
special effects guys and uh try and make
it all as as correct as possible but
also that the show is very fast it's
fastpaced and also that Dodger has a
certain flare to it so we we didn't want
to get too hung up on actually how long
these procedures would take but then
also coming from the kind of the Navy
style back then was to was to act very
very quickly to cause as minimal amount
of pain as possible and to get the
surgery done very quickly and roughly so
um we had speed and flare into these
procedures um but yeah it's very
interesting what's so interesting as
well with Jack is that you know
obviously he's an established character
in Oliver Twist people are really
familiar with him but you're giving a
whole new kind of story to him a whole
new life to him what was it like to kind
of build up that character like what
kind of like kind of you know character
preparation and work did you put into
kind of fleshing out who you wanted him
to be well I I I uh you know
I I didn't think he should be the kind
of classic Cockney I thought about doing
that and um between myself and um the
showrunner and uh directors and everyone
I think we kind of the Ed to not go for
the proper kind of old school copney
like proper Dodger and and and again
bring back that idea that he's running
away from that and trying to push that
aside and trying to build his way up in
society um so um
vocally I'm quite different to what we
think of as being dodo however in the
scenes with
Fagan I wanted to kind of play around
and it's a hard one to do to kind of do
two accents and not for for an audience
not go doing but it was a choice to to
uh to to kind of go a little bit more
into the old Dodger with my scenes with
Fagen only only slightly but just
dropping teas and things and um and
being a bit more like the old school
Dodger and then in my scenes with bell
and with any members of higher Society
where I'm trying to slightly be a be a
be a different person I'm I kind of Posh
it up as it were um so that was
important for me um I like the aspect of
the fact he was you know he's kind of
got this kind of almost addiction to
gambling and risk taking and that harks
back to his old life um but he's but but
he's but he's actually truly talented at
surgery and sees surgery as a as a as a
platform to elevate him um but he's
constantly struggling with these with
these two worlds that he feel the place
where he knows he's from and shunned of
because of it and um the place where he
thinks that he could be which isn't
necessarily in High Society but dis
respected um so it was uh it was good
fun to kind of play with these
two versions of himself that how he
thinks of himself I think he's he's
confident but also I think his
confidence helps cover cover up his his
uh his his insecurities that he carries
with him kind of touching on that that
past that Jack is grappling with with
Fagan coming back you know it's
something I I asked David as well
yesterday during the interviews but you
know it's it there's like a a an element
of ambiguity between how these two
characters feel about each other if that
is like a genuine care between Jack and
Fagan or if it's kind of like an
obligation and I am curious for you like
how did you play Jack's like emotional
attachment to Fagan does it feel like
like something from his past that he
just has to deal with or is there like a
genuine care there for what happens to
Fagan and his fate I think um Fagan was
the the was the only person in his
preious life that gave him any kind of
love any kind of um
care or or attention
he took him in from the cold gave him a
roof over his head gave him a purpose in
life not for the best causes or reasons
his morals are very questionable uh they
were Crooks they were criminals
thieves um the bad side of uh Victorian
England but um they had each other's
backs supposedly and looked after each
other so I think I think Dodger sees
Fagan is uh very much a
father uh and and um provides that role
for him in an early age but then he's
also he's betrayed by him
and really struggles with that betrayal
and he think he's holds a huge amount of
resentment and anger towards Fagen but
despite that he is his his dad in many
ways and um there's no kind of running
away from that or hiding that so he's
he's constantly kind of he's either
shouting and um having a go at Fagan or
he's being slowly lured and pulled back
into a way and a life that he actually
flourished in and they were a pack you
know they were like they were like they
were like dogs really and and Fagan was
the was the head of the pack was the
alpha and um it's fun to if if you're
lost in the world it's it's nice to know
that you have a family that you have a
gang or you have a posy of people who
rely on you and who look after you the
trouble is is that
um that trust was broken and I think
that's truly heartbreaking for Dodger I
know people often ask you know like what
part of yourself did you bring to this
character but I'm curious like was there
any element of Dodger that stuck with
you after you wrapped on the series it's
hard to put it into words but I think
there's a you know there is a part of
you as an act that goes into every
character there has to be otherwise it's
not a performance um and there's
something you leave um or that they
leave with
you um that helps you kind of grow as an
individual I've always thought that
figuring out exactly what that is I I
don't really know um
but he's loyal
um and he's
um and he's confident in his in his
ability and um perhaps that's something
I I have taken on I love that um I also
really love that this Series has this
like little burgeoning romance between
Jack and Belle starting you know with
the first couple of episodes we don't
really see where that's going but can
you tease a little bit about exploring
that side of Jack and cuz it's it's fun
to see him like kind of experiencing
some like romance while also balancing
like oh my gosh my past is like knocking
at my door yeah I think it goes back
down to love really uh he he's uh his
experience of love has not been the best
uh so I think he's a little a little
afraid and intimidated by the idea of of
love in general but yet he desperately
wants it as we all do um but it means
that you have to expose yourself it
means you have to completely let let let
everything go and um that's that's a
very hard thing for people to do in
general and I think that's something the
Dodger struggles with because it makes
you vulnerable and he hates being
vulnerable because he has been
vulnerable in the past and that has
bitten
him however with bell it's slightly
different because there's this um I
don't know this this competition level
um the she respects him hugely for for
what he has achieved and who he is as a
surgeon and there aren't many people in
that Circle that
do and
um I think he admires her tenacity and
her audaciousness and at the
beginning I think he just thinks of her
as um uh another High Society tough that
doesn't know what's going on has no
connection with the real world and I
think he's quite in some ways he's
correct and she doesn't really know
what's in the real world but she is
willing to um to try to experience that
and to who as supposed to just sitting
on her Laurels and enjoying her High
Life um as the governor's daughter she
has the potential and interest and
desire to want to help people and I
think that's where they connect I think
Dodger really wants to help people and
so does Lady Bell but they're just from
two very different parts of the world
and of
society um and it's that that brings
them together their they want to help
and Pro progress um or progress medicine
um which has kind of been stuck in a
somewhat rut um you know back then it
was the Mortal mortality rate was insane
like even if you survived the procedure
the likelihood was that you were going
to die of infection that was just like
70% of surgeries endered in infection
and um even if it was successful you you
die um so the progress made back then
was huge in terms of just um early forms
of antiseptic and and um at ether as
well which is you know roughly in the
right time zone as what we we're talking
about we we slightly
um we slightly pushed the timings a
little bit um I think one of the
procedures we do in the show actually
took place in 1920 something um and we
we pull it back slightly but we we tried
to be quite accurate as to what the
Innovations were happening in the
medical um and bring it to to Australia
which was quite late in getting all of
that absolutely and as we wind down the
interview I am interested to know do you
think there is the potential for more
stories to be told uh in this little
corner of the the dickan world um are
you hopeful for a season two I mean
dickins is still going I mean there's
there's a reason for that he writes
great stories that people can still
relate to and obviously this is a Twist
on it no pun intended but it is a Twist
on it um it is it is far more colorful
um it is bright and it is fastpaced more
much more so than Dickens novels um but
using using
his you know his his larger brush
Strokes to to create a a slightly
enhanced and different world I think
there's lots of scope um stories get
retold and retold R told constantly and
um it's finding new wonderful ways and
effective ways of doing
that yeah so I mean Dickens is still
alive and well excellent well thank you
so much Thomas I really appreciate
this no you're very welcome I'm glad you
enjoyed the
show